[Music]
happy father's day
welcome to sidetrek on sci-fi sunday
which that's um i'm going with that
little tagline there for all of our live
shows
yeah it just feels like it should be a
saturday morning show with like you know
we should play games and things but
we're not gonna do that
but hey i'm here with our stormy doing a
little bit of a hangout we've got no
topic planned even though i've got an
idea of something i want to talk about
but
no topic plans so guys get in the
comments anything you want to ask us you
can go for it ama all the way
whatever you want to do so stormy how
you did lindsay what you've been up to i
am doing well
had a great week
doing fun uh
you know my uh allergies are trying to
uh kill me in my sleep but other than
that
i say well it's it's been a good week
for the sidetrack channel anyway we hit
10 000 as i'm sure everybody in that
knows
10 000 subscribers who freaking knew it
at 10 months ago when i started this
silly little channel because of me you
and spencer chatting about it and
talking about it but
we just wanted to do a star trek video
and then i did this but
so we'll do our normal little thing
about what you've been watching this
week or what you've been
saying caught your eye this week and
then i do have a question for you which
i hope
okay all right so my question kind of
um
strange new worlds the latest episode
was really good uh instant mouths hair
was a little bit shorter i mean it
wasn't the
you know the the matterhorn you know
it wasn't like you were
in the village of zermatt looking up at
the mighty matterhorn it was
tamer
my god like two three episodes ago it
was so distracting it's like oh it's a
ski jump now wow
it was that guy from the marvel wasn't
it that had the uh
it got crazy it did get crazy uh but you
know it
again it's um
stranger worlds continues to impress
um
and i really do like ants and mountain
as an actor i really haven't i think i
still believe in the
other thing before and
but this
is doing well and i'm i'm i'm happy
always uh to catch it i like that
they've shown brought a bit more of his
character through because he is quite a
um
uh it's a bit of a cheeky chappy sort of
thing
but i think they brought a bit more of
his character through from the pike we
saw in discovery and i like that yes
he's he's got a few little quips here
and there that he didn't he was a bit
more straight-laced in discovery i
thought where he's a bit more cheeky
this time he was playing pike from
the movies i think where he was a bit
more straight and sort of like proper
starfleet captain whereas now he's a bit
more fun which i like that
what paramount plus here is on in three
days
three days three days
i don't know
strangely well i'm waiting i'm holding
off i pay for this down paramount plus
through other subscriptions so i'm going
to take advantage of it damn it
even though i've not been watching
prodigy because i didn't think it was on
apparently it's on um
nickelodeon or something here and i'm
like oh i've got that that's right yeah
it is a partnership with a little idiot
i never thought i just never thought so
i've not watched it
i i i kind of liked it you know i mean
it was you know
trainee you know trainer janeway you
know the ai that's still has the mug of
coffee i mean it was just
it's really i mean it's a kid show but
it is really good of course like i've
seen clips
great i love this don't like design but
other than that i think it's correct you
know enough is and this is totally
unfair of me i uh start you know i
watched uh started watching bad batch
and it's like well this is a kids show
not a kids show
i mean it's you know it's not real i
mean it is animated so you don't get the
blood splatter that you would in like a
tarantino film but it was you know had a
lot of really complex themes
you know and it was i really enjoyed it
and yeah i love the clone wars as well
to be honest i thought yeah yeah
similar similar thing it added so much
to the story which you don't normally
get when they do an animated series
based on a tv show it's normally a bit
separate and you think oh it doesn't
that was like no this is part of the
universe just because it's animated
don't mean anything it's gotta be it's
gotta still be a certain quality right i
don't think a lot of animated spin-off
shows have done that but i remember like
the stargate spin-off um infinity well
crosstalk it was cool now um but it was
it
very very little to do with the tv
series
you'd be like it was like completely
different sort of thing
but
i watched the talking about perfect star
trek um i did watch the next orville
episode
right
and it was just i saw a meme or
something and so they'll take this this
um episode of star trek and this episode
of the orville and this episode of um
strange new worlds and stick it in a
blender and out pops episode three of
the orville and i'm just like yeah it
was very tricky it was it was very like
two or three next generation episodes
jumped to mind when i'm like going to
watch that and thought that would be
good it was good episode it was a good
episode i liked it but
but yeah
another thing i watched as um
i started watching uh
ms marvel
i've not seen the amp yeah the uh is you
know story um
a little middle eastern uh high school
student that's been picked on
um by at school and
pressures of her uh middle eastern
family
um
he becomes kind of a superhero and then
uh because her nana has got these
bracelets that are handed down and their
parents don't want her to see him or
whatever
uh and so then you know comes out really
really good show you know i liked it
and then the poor uh the poor actress
goes on to be picked on in social media
because she's not white or whatever the
[ __ ]
you know and it's just like the
characters getting picked on by
the pretty girl the cheerleaders at
school
in real life social media picks up and
it's like are you kidding me come on
yeah
oh it was frustrating i think people
think you'd remember this as a child
they're having to go out i mean don't
get me wrong these are also the most
extreme comments a lot of people don't
like the show because they think it's a
bit childish i think but um from what
i've read it is it is a teen show it is
a teen romance show that is what it is
and people don't particularly like that
902 or no marvel 902 or no but um
the whole woke agenda we weren't going
to woke today because we've done videos
on before and it makes people really
angry because i think people different
people have different opinions on what
woke means i don't know what it means
it's just it's um
and the original meaning of the word is
a good thing
um i want tv shows to be woke you know i
want them to be awake at least to these
things and agenda i think good sci-fi is
awake
um but what
the thing is that people get very angry
about work a lot of them do have a good
point though some tv shows
they do just push an agenda for for a
purpose i don't think miss marvel is i
think they're just
i do think hollywood has been racist for
a really really long time and now
they're trying really hard to balance
the books a little bit
um if you think about actors like denzel
washington he should be like a proper
a-lister and he isn't really
um he's always sort of been a bit like
a minus something um
uh will smith obviously may be a bit
different but
hollywood's been racist a long time and
and sexist horribly sexist it still is
today i mean why didn't
the star from screen say i'm not coming
back for a sixth one is because they
wouldn't offer her the same money
as as the male stars and but she is
there's never campbell she is the star
so
yeah i mean she is one thing she's a
great actress you know
she she was a great actress back when
she was doing oh god what was the name
tv show
hang on a second
my alzheimer's fog is starting to lift
party of five party of five oh yeah yeah
and uh she was great then and then she
got this horror franchise it's like what
the studio is thinking the only reason
anyone's going to go see it is because
she's the main character
you know
this is not i just love that there's a
there's a statistic that always shocks
me anything if you think hollywood isn't
sexist
um you're wrong
because um gal gadot for the first um
yeah wonder woman movie and less than
the bloke from 90210 got when he did
sharknado 6.
you know and so and that is just insane
um and i didn't believe that me and when
i saw because i see you know you see the
meme on facebook oh yeah right i bet i
100 but that's not true so i googled it
and it was
that's true
um it's not much but he earned a little
bit more than gal gadot for a major
franchise but you know
it is sexy so how do you think it's
trying to i do think there's some
creators that are trying to balance the
books and sometimes they go too far
um i can't help but watch the picard
serie episode three of series two
there's this bit where they when it's um
seven of nine and um
uh oh the
the other woman oh forgot a name and the
alcohol
exo
yes yes sir so yeah exactly
gerardi no that's no journey's the one
that turns into a ball control right
yeah um but anyway so um they're in a
bit and then they're in like modern 20
20 24 or whatever it is and they just
there's a story story story and then
they do a big commentary on racism and
then they stop and they carry on doing
the story again and it's stuck out like
a sore thumb it's a big racial sore
thumb
something and he's like because yeah all
right make the comment but don't make it
stand out like a big huge
you know just like just tell them
the whole thing about um
uh hispanics getting captured by ice
was that the storyline yeah well no this
actually that led on to the storyline
this was actually just a brief this was
just a scene when they went well why is
there still racism oh there was oh it
was still racist in 21st it just took
out then they went onto the ice thing
which actually at least the ice thing
had a point to the story
that the bit i'm on about was just a
scene randomly in the middle of the
sentence sort of thing it's just like oh
look over there oh no there's racism
over there
oh but no this thing over it was like
that it was random
that annoys me
yeah because
here in california that was more of a
dot that those scenes were more of a
documentary than uh
science fiction you see when they
brought all the when they brought all
that up in picard i thought they were
going um
they were hooking it up with uh
something dealing with uh
the bell riots from uh deep space nine
yeah it was mentioned wasn't it and it
was
it never went there i thought well oh my
god this is gonna be some sort of
continuation on that and something he's
gonna screw up and then all of a sudden
you know
but it just it was just no
no it was the wrong key wasn't it when
the bell right supposed to be this year
wasn't supposed to be 20 22. well you
right well um
i think picard was set in 2024 isn't it
see i thought it was um
i thought the card was season two was
six months before the bell riots
you might be right
i know
let's see if they do it in another
episode
[Music]
2024 september 2024 so this is so picard
season two took place like six
months-ish
before
so i thought that was a oh my god it's
the same issues and it's leading up and
it's gonna be awesome and
maybe we'll see
haven't explained
yeah when they're big bad now
because curtainment always does that
that's what kurtzman does
he goes oh there's a little bit of star
trek there's a little star trek there
but i screw you i'm going to do
something completely different and do
whatever i want and peel over and
that's what he always does
i think we ought to see moff start um
writing for star trek
kind of get away from tardis and just
enterprise i just want somebody that's a
proper fan of star trek and respect
we've talked about canon before but i i
think canon should be respected um but i
but i'm not like like really anal about
it either i'm not like
it must be at all costs i'm not like
that
um and i do think things change because
you know like um
what was the exam pleased uh i didn't
mind that on enterprise they had
holographic like um
communication devices right because
actually like on a big screen like in
tng in tng that was futuristic she
couldn't talk to anybody like we're
talking to each other like over the
phone like this
and but now you can so all of a sudden
that doesn't look very futuristic
anymore so you know it's i didn't mind
too much that they sort of like went oh
okay we're gonna we've gotta actually
try to make this look like
relevant
but um some technology point of view but
i do mind if they just completely change
everything and when the jj abrams movies
they completely change everything from
movie to movie i mind that
that makes me angry the kelvin timeline
the kirk timeline yeah what makes no
goddamn sense timeline
that's what it should be
uh
so speaking of wokeitude since you
brought it up and you love talking about
this topic because of all the
interesting interaction you get with the
audience
i started i watched the first two
i watched the two
the first two episodes of the most
anti-woke thing probably
on
on on television now and that's the boys
yeah i love that shirt
and it was like it was really engaging i
mean you know we started off with some
poor girl from the midwest you know
getting raped
well okay
the first thing is when their whole is
holding on to the um girl's hands and
he's it's the girl he loves and the
speed guy
pops like a balloon
i was just like oh my christ so i'm just
like because did did everyone else see
that it's like but you know i said i
said to you last week tonight it's like
it's it's it's it's you know it's
ridiculous and it's it's a lot paul but
it's what would happen if you had
superheroes
the the the boys is what you would get
if uh quentin tarantino was doing
something in the mcu
oh my god yeah yeah yeah that's a good
way of putting it yeah that is you know
and i was wondering if there was uh
something that came out of that if
why um
you know why are some of the actors you
know also in uh some of the kelvin
timeline star trek shows you know
i mean you got simon pegg he's the dad
right then you've got
butcher i mean he they all he's like is
there some
friend circle there that's making it
i don't know but carl urban's brilliant
in everything he does
i wish he got like with a dread movie
to be honest i wish i'd make some more
like you know house of rohirrim or
something but yeah yeah
and i always respected carla i like i
loved carl urban from um
chronicles of riddick he was in that and
i i thought he was great in that
um kill the beast
but then he did um
he did uh dread and the thing i liked
about that was a lot of these actors
when they do films like this when
there's a helmet or something something
that covers the face they'll always put
in the contract that they have to have
so much screen time would like it off
right so then that's when you always get
these awkward shots like in robocop when
he has to take his head off because they
have to it was in his contract they had
to have like so much percentage of him
like this in the new robocop movie they
did it the helmet kept opening so you
could see his full face and i'm just
like
i
contracted that carl urban refused they
said oh well do you want to do the thing
no judge dredd wears a helmet so i will
wear the hell any war the whole movie
doesn't take off
i'm just like and he was a big star at
that point that was you know hoping to
hang the franchise on him so i don't
know if it was a mistake or not but you
know um it was just it was just
fantastic i thought i actually really
like that movie i think it's one of
those films um it wasn't appreciated the
time but actually to stand up you know
it's um
i think i just think he's great actor
and i love him as bones
and i love how they had that little
thing in the jj abrams movie when they
explained why they're calling bones that
was one of the things i did like let's
just go just gone through a divorce and
all she left me was my bones
she got the whole planet in the divorce
yeah exactly i did like that a little
bit
um
so the question i was going to ask you
oh yes
yeah so you have an avionics an aviation
background i think it's fair to say yes
right so
and you understand space travel and
things and you have a little bit of
understanding of that area as well
um so
in
i'm just gonna say what in sci-fi do you
think of the series that have actually
done really well with designing ships
and things that are
pretty accurate or pretty um
um
that's what i'm looking for
obeys the laws of physics realism bring
out that's a bit of realism to them a
base laws of physics actually if you're
going to build a starship is what it
would be like
um or or could be and what the series
that you just think
no why why do the ships look like that
there's like and i'll throw in the hat
straight away
star trek
there is absolutely no reason why all
the stars the federation starships look
like that
i know they say it's to do with like
warp and stuff but above you through
warping that's not it doesn't bother it
and so why do all the starships look all
that that pretty
and when it doesn't make any sense at
all
um
but i just wondered if you had any
thoughts about what series does anything
jump to mind you think
actually that that that is that does
make sense and i haven't asked you about
this before and so i'm completely thrown
in the deep end sorry but
uh well the the probably the best
um
that really does work hard to get it
right is the expanse
the uh
when they are when when the script is
written
the
type of of
the
colors of the paper they use
shows the type of gravity that they're
in
you know is it high gravity is it on
earth is it on a station you know it act
or is it weightless i mean they they go
to the
so far
to get it right is they color code the
pages depending on what kind of gravity
the actors are allegedly supposed to
expose
and um
that limited detail is amazing
it is it is um
but let's see
if you have to
create a warp shell let's just you know
sticking with
you know whatever they explain on like
memory alpha or whatever the word
wikipedia or whatnot
it seems to be that the cells would have
to be
symmetrical
and encompass the entirety of the
spacecraft like the
the dish of the enterprise would be in
the middle not in front
yeah
the warp shell
would also deal with
bits and particles of micrometeoroids or
so whatever in front of the starship
which is also
the deflector dish should be the biggest
thing on it because you're if you're
flying in multiples
logarithms of the speed of light then
the
potential energy of an impact is
astronomical no pun intended
yeah well that's why it projects the
there is a lot of power that goes
through the star trek
deflector array and it projects a
b in front of it but yeah i agree with
you
mccabe also mentions battlestar
galactica
and uh they did a pretty good job of um
you know the the space scenes there's
there's no sound in space you hear the
radio chatter you know you hear whatever
noise you hear is coming from
uh the pilot's point of view of the
horror of the engines or the apu or
st or
radios or whatever
only time you hear something is like uh
you know
adama asked starbuck what do you hear
she says nothing but the rain and it's
the micrometeoroids hitting the uh the
canopy on here like that how do you like
that scene
so that's i think another one that
actually one of the few shows i think
they do it quite a lot and there's quite
a few like anime and stuff where i think
they do a really nice job
um but actually the series of firefly
um i thought they did a really nice job
with one of the um they didn't for the
movie but in the series obviously the
firefly looks the way it does and it's
got streamlined it's got engines it's
got slightly some aerodynamics factors
to it but because it comes into
atmosphere
but then the um
the
inner core planets have these big
cruisers
but they look like little cities
yeah they were you know had a base and
like towers that look like buildings
almost like skyscrapers like skyscrapers
i think and actually i i really always
thought that is so that is perfect
because
aerodynamics don't matter you can build
a ship to be whatever you just you know
you can slap an engine on the iss and
fly it to the moon if you want to
there's no
um there's no you know there's no
there's no structural reason why it
doesn't have to be anything like a
strong you can make really big ships in
space it doesn't have to be as strong as
what you respect because it doesn't have
to come to an atmosphere
well there are structural um
structural things you have to taking
into account
uh like the uh
the skyscraper thing the is really bad
design
because the let's uh
so the um here you have the basic ship
and there's all these little skyscrapers
on top yeah well if the thrusters were
on this side right the edge
so all of the skyscrapers would be under
a tremendous force to bend back
so you have a lot of structural uh the
possibility of structural
failure
along this line here along the edge of
the skyscraper so you'd have it bending
back until it snaps
so you always want your mass
to be along
your line of thrust the closer it is the
line of thrust the less stress is on the
uh the spaceship
so the whole thing
was quite hard for that to be
an issue in space where there's no
inertia and there's no
oh there's inertia yeah so i just go
back just about to correct myself not as
much inertia
let's think obviously when you get into
like pushing you know like 0.7 or or
something of the speed of light then it
matters because you are generating your
own gravity and you you do you just want
space time um but in like
you know slower speeds say getting from
i mean in firefly they don't travel
particularly quickly they go from like
here to mars in days
you know there's just quite a long
travel you know they don't have light
speed they don't have
things like that
it's not so much as the speed is the
acceleration
so if you puttering along at
you know i don't know 0.2 g's
you don't get much of a lever arm action
on this skyscraper
but if you're loading up to like five
g's then you get a lot of bend
so but you if you go to point two g's
you can still get to the speed of light
because you're still accelerating as
long as you're accelerating at slow
speed
long arms like this matter and
as for the international space station
it is very difficult
to
uh you got to take a lot of care and
getting it up to a higher orbit you know
it always decays down
so you have to really be careful because
every all everything's off the line of
thrust you've got all these solar cells
and other modules going out at 90 degree
angles so you have to be very careful to
nudge it to a higher orbit
but that's because it's relatively close
and it still looks effect by a little
bit of gravity isn't it because that's
why it pulls in i mean the thing the
gateway project they're building just
looks like an iss station and that
they're going to push that over to the
moon and if they ever build it um
but yeah but i always saw that you don't
need to be
pretty
in space that's that was i think my
point was and the enterprise is pretty i
mean it's a beautiful ship you know but
you don't need to be the spitfire you
don't need to be a spitfire you don't
need to be
an attractive machine
to operate in space unless you're going
to come into the atmosphere and then
you've got a whole other slew of
problems
um
i also like like the star wars designs
they look amazing but are they
practical but they actually do go into
an atmosphere but they've got anti-grav
drives and things so then i suppose it
makes it irrelevant doesn't i suppose
yeah um
probably the thing um
discounting the whole uh issue of
available energy
the x-wing the x-wing is probably very
well designed because everything's on
close to a single line of thrust they've
got the the thrusters on the x-wings and
themselves and so you have
a larger area where the the fuselage can
be in that
pocket that envelope
um
what is it the core um
i mean the tie fighters are kind of
decent too because they're
narrow and they're closer to the line of
thrust
uh there's one
and it's not the millennium falcon it's
where it's got a big long body and it's
got a long arm and then there's like the
cockpit over here
thing wasn't it yeah i want to say
corvette but i know that's wrong
yeah
i think i think the um
what's the thing the bubbles uh babylon
five the star fury
google
i always thought that was a really good
design for like a fighter for space and
without the engines and it could flip
and things and the engines were quite
wide quite far apart so that you know
you could change thrust and you could
literally just i always thought that was
as if if you're gonna have a fighter i'm
never quite sure where the power came
from or where the core was
because it seemed to be that's where the
where the blood sat and there didn't
seem to be a lot of space or anything
else even though they did mention it a
few times you know like the radiation
leaks and things on fighters and stuff
um ian says says it was the star fury
thank you um so um oh so that was one of
the most realistic
fighters and i always loved the way it
launched
the way it sort of had these little
prongs is good and then just dropped
you know even battle style actually i've
had these long shooting um
hubs i'm saying why would you do that
you just have a door and just drop it at
the bottom of the ship surely right um
simplify you know that's what i think
but
i always love that ship
um
hello to walter bishop um he says sorry
just joined
walter we're we glad to have you
i said in space there's no gravity there
is gravity in space there's gravity
everywhere
but it just may not affect you as
readily as you think i mean um
if you go if you look through the
equation f equals m a force equals mass
times acceleration
even though there may be a gravitational
body one billion you know light years
away it still has an effect on you very
very minor there's still gravity
remember gravity is a wave
and so we were talking about creating
your own basically what i was talking
about if you
okay
i'm triggered
we're not talking
calm down america
um for the americans just gonna don't
start a war just because he's uh just
because he disagreed with you
um if you travel faster
you generate your own gravity as well
just what we were talking about wasn't
it um
calm down
black holes of gravity walls we have
started argument oh my god
now that
okay so
going back to the woke [ __ ] right
[Laughter]
thinking we've never landed on the moon
is
so anti-crazy woke it's just not even
anti it's just
i got yelled at a lot in the video
because we did about the fake moon
landings in the conspiracy video they
did for my other channel but in the
whole video we all talk about how
there's lots of these conspiracies and
there are reasons why these conspiracies
happened and i generally did believe for
years that we didn't land on the moon
because there are certain things about
it but i i i fell for the for the for
the you know the um the lie the story
was just so
enticing you know i just i fell for it
but then as i got older and i i was a
kid i was literally like 14 15 or so oh
wow okay and but as i learned more and i
started to learn actually that nasa
really actually didn't expect the
astronauts to come back and things like
that that they genuinely believe well
these this might be a death sentence
nixon had to speak his and his
alternative each ready yeah all the um
all the all the new york times and stuff
had their um
the two things ready
they're safe they're not safe
um
and there's a there's a fact about that
i learned for the video actually was
that um nasa wouldn't insure the
astronauts so if they died their
families would get no you know no money
basically um so because they they were
so not confident so what they did was
the astronauts got a load of postcards
made and signed them the idea being that
if they died which was a distinct
possibility they could sell the
postcards and make some money
that's how confident they were they were
coming back
um but anyway in this video we said and
the end result was we went to the moon
the amount of [ __ ] i still got are
saying that you're soon it's fake you're
saying it's fake because watch the video
to the end
just watch the video to the end
stop shouting
just
stop having a go
um
yeah calling woke [ __ ] yeah it is i'm
sorry it is
um
i'm just going to make a point on woke
and i tried
um
well i'm evil i keep taking us down this
just this this rabbit
right
hole
if the american steps out of place guys
we just shout aluminium at him a lot and
he calms down
no i'm with you on that you brits have
an extra eye americans you know we uh we
just don't have that you know we you
don't you say it's still there you just
don't say it no i think
aluminum in in in the english in the
american english dictionary there's no
way we're missing an eye which is where
the derivation is great
um i i actually agree with walter on
this one
a little bit
i actually believe for a long time that
we landed on the moon but we just faked
the images because we didn't have a
camera that would work
and i thought that's why we had so many
anomalies but then i learned a bit more
about photography
right right right and found out a lot of
those anonymous anonymities are
explained by overexposure and things so
i was just like so i actually genuinely
leave that but yeah anyway we won't go
into that i mean i'll pop that back up
for a second you know walter
yeah though the walter bit so one thing
you have to understand about stanley
kubrick i mean he he's a very serious
filmmaker you know and he always shoots
on location
so there you go
you've also got the james bond scene
right
it wasn't mean it wasn't moon maker but
it was one of them and james bond just
randomly runs across a moon set and
there's a moon set and there's a lander
and then he runs back he goes through
another door and runs off
and that's that's it that's all the
scene and there's just like astronauts
like on a movie set yeah
um it was um it was roger moore
but i forget that's just like i and that
was always the hint of like oh did you
let me know somewhere
[Music]
i was just thinking spaceships are
designed to look pretty and i would
actually say even a lot of the expanse
ships that they spend a lot of effort to
be expensive they're very very pretty
but i did like how they did like the big
city ship on the
one right and it was just a big circle
sort of thing and it was not pretty dark
and you know i think i really like that
i think star trek i've always just made
ships that they could turn into models
and i think star wars is the same they
want to sell a toy so that's right um
but i always impressed me that
occasionally when you see
tv shows and they go you know what
actually
it doesn't have to look pretty it can be
functional and i always feel like that
the
the advanced i think has one of the
the prettiest ships in terms of just
modeling and that was the razorback
oh yeah
i mean that thing was just awesome
you know the way they had the interior
you know for for the the the
gravity-controlled chairs you know kind
of on a gyroscope and it was just
god i love that yeah i did like that
plus it had the the virgin galactic
logo on the back spine of it
you know and after you know it had like
a the razorbacks silhouette was at the
top now and that was just
i loved it
so i think
i would make a point though actually
about
when they were building the stealth
bomber right they painted it black
yes the air force painted it black and
then i said well is is that the best
color because goes well at night
actually black isn't a very good color
for for an aircraft really you want to
paint it um
like a dark blue or something because
black and and night actually stands out
a little bit it's also not the best
color for the um the heat it doesn't
absorb heat as well so so ideally you
would you'd paint it like almost like a
dark gray
but they said well so why did you paint
it black because we wanted the pilots to
feel cool
and it's that's basically the reason
a lot of the pilots were a little bit
unsure about this thing and they wanted
to it to look cool
so i actually think even if we're
designing spaceships in the future will
there be an element of us wanting the
ship just you know
to look cool
because we can't help ourselves
well i mean look at um
[Music]
look at the saturn v
right very functional spaceship went all
the way the moon and back several times
um
and look at uh elon musk's starship
yeah i mean that thing is
yeah i mean that is just gorgeous that
is you know and um you know and the
virgin galactic uh
spaceship too is gorgeous
i'm gonna disagree with you on that one
i think it looks like it's gonna break
but
there's a reason why we won't go into
the argument now but i don't think it's
gorgeous i think it's an ugly thing but
but we'll go into it
there's a reason why that we won't go
into that i've been looking at a virgin
atlantic aircraft quite a lot recently
but that's a minion looking thing but um
i will agree with you that the statue do
you think though the starship elon musk
starship you know when he swapped it to
the stainless steel because it's cheaper
it looks like a freaking death trap
you can actually see bits where the
steel's distorted and you can almost see
the ribbon
through it yeah mm-hmm i'm just like
that looks like that's gonna break
like i don't want to get that that's
gonna die die
if you look at the the earlier i think
like serial number two three and four
and then look at uh serial number 24 25
the uh
the quality is much much better you see
less less rippling and a lot of the
rippling is you know it's
like they'll weld it together at night
and then you get what's called oil
canning
the little rippling will will happen
during the day because the ship heats up
he's also said that simply
he could build a starship that is
prettier and look more futuristic
whenever goosebumps but what they want
to do is build a starship that they can
launch a thousand of them a day
and so it's going to be functional and
the bare minimum
but he's still he's not stupid he still
knows that it's gotta look
cool and it's got a lot futuristic but
it looks like something from a 1950
sci-fi movie which is what i love about
it i know right the other the going back
to the sr-71 one reason and you did
bring it up
um there's a reason it was a coated
black
was
uh the heat
it reflects heat and they didn't want
the heat signature because the thing the
sr-71 is
really
i mean it has a problem with heating
because it goes so fast against the
atmosphere so they would the skin
literally starts to glow
and so the black paint is more resilient
to that a high
speed that friction atmospheric friction
and you have a much lower threshold of a
heat signature that you have to deal
with in terms of being invisible
they did it for the um the the stealth
bomber as well as then they painted that
black and they said that actually it's
still fighter yeah it's not it's not the
best color um but when the paint they
use is that absorbent stealth and stuff
radar absorption
do you do do you want to hit this spit
or should we just pretend really see if
you still think ever watching astronauts
gone wild the moonlighting happened look
up van allen belt it's a radiation belt
oh yeah so this is the whole thing about
the the van allen belt and its radiation
there's a really good um
there's a really good video from joe
scott
explaining this uh line of thinking
the van allen belt is for one thing you
you fly through it the uh van allen belt
is not equal in intensity all around the
earth it is not it doesn't have a
contiguous
and so when nasa flies
asteroids yeah i mean it thins out i
mean it's just it's a it's it's it's not
contiguous it's not the same it's not a
complete the
bits and pieces slices of the shell of
the van allen belt
is not the same as another slice so you
can actually you know use
scientific equipment to find out where
it's thinnest and then you fly through
that
and the exposure to the van allen belt
let's say you sat in it it's still not a
lethal dose as i know
everyone says oh my god it's radiation
well the sun's also radiating
you know so
you just have to understand that
radiation there's electromagnetic
radiation which can or cannot really um
either it can boil your soup in the
microwave or it can give you sunburn or
it can also
turn you know your solar panels and have
them create electricity for you so don't
be too scared about the issue of the
word radiation
i mean for god's sakes i can say
aluminium i'm pretty sure everyone else
can understand what radiation is
so there are center parts of the
van allen belt that are less reactive
less radioactive and
you can always fly through it
yeah
really quickly so they said you want to
go through that because actually there's
several there's belt several belts
you're only actually going through for
like three minutes or something it ain't
nothing right you know you're zipping
through
yeah yeah i'm saying they said that the
van allen belt would be potentially
deadly and which is what they were
worried about particularly
for the thingy launch um as if there was
a particularly heavy sole store and we
hit it because when we get hit by social
it's the radiation of the van the
vanilla kind of captures it
and it holds it for a while so if
a solar storm hit us at the same time
you're going through the belt
then it could be a problem right right
but nowadays we monitor that really
really well
so we would know um but also yeah um it
doesn't help though when the nasa um
engineer when they did an orion video
was talk talked about it said now we
just have to figure out how to go
through allen belts and i'm just like
actually you know for the apollo
missions we didn't care about the health
of the
astronauts that much so we didn't worry
about it but actually normally just go
through it really quick and go through
the thin bit at an angle as we get the
angle right and it's not really a
problem yeah the the issue of going to
the moon there were more problematic
things than the van allen belt
that's true uh starship has no launch
escape system except for the upper stage
is just considered
you know
the uh so why is the top guy
say on video we cannot go back to the
moon uh congress
there you go one word answer
we can't go back to the moon because of
congress my answer for that actually is
health and safety i would still argue
in 1969 they were in a cold war
they just wanted to get to the moon by
any cost and safety
was secondary
now
that has to work 100 of the time you
cannot have failure
um you so all of a sudden health and
safety is much more important so getting
the technology to get to the moon is
doable getting the total knowledge to
get to the moon safely 100 times out of
100 is hard you know it's like that's a
different
kettle of fish
i don't know whether it's me the the
where on earth did the term that's a
different kettle of fish come from
i know this is slightly frustrating
how does that mean
i would not doubt it's something about
shakespeare but uh walter bishop and
this quote right here does come come up
with something cool
he said he'd go back in a second but
they destroyed the technology so 60s
tech can't be made again very good point
um
the what was a for one thing the
technology is around
if you go to huntsville alabama or cape
canaveral take the tour you'll see all
sorts of
equipment and rockets or in pieces of
rockets from the saturn fives in the
moonland or they're all in museums
the reason we have all of these is
because richard nixon canceled apollo 18
19 and 20.
for whatever [ __ ] up reason he
canceled him
and back in the back in this era of the
60s and 70s we fully expected you know
as soon as armstrong put his foot on the
moon he said well now the next step's
more yes i mean that was the from the
americans point of view that was
accepted
you know fed a complete that was our
national destiny ah mars is next
i mean we all felt we were going to mars
and there was even plans uh to go to to
build a ver another the the next step
beyond saturn v is called the saturn
nova
and the plans of those things are
probably around some place
uh the problem with you know the that
60s tech is it's
62 years old
and we've come a long way
but the good point the thing that you're
making the point is is when we stop
doing something
stop making something we do by not by
mike we do forget like um
somehow another i got into an argument
online about plastic straws right yeah
you know somebody i think i forget who
it is starbucks or somebody you know has
these little fiber straws right
and they're you know someone was
complaining that they kind of collapsed
and they get wishy-washy and they
affected
all that just true
but in the 60s and 70s we had paper
straws
you know they were waxed and we'd gotten
to the point where you did they didn't
collapse it didn't get soggy they didn't
change the flavor of the your drink so
somewhere between the 60s and today we
forgot how to make paper straws
so
i mean your points taken you know we
have to continually be developing
technology and when we don't you know
people like elon musk has to go back to
the literal drawing board and start from
scratch yeah
i saw this one that nasa was building
the when they designed the new heavy
lift rocket the sls and one of the
things they did was they dragged um
one of the russian engines they had out
of storage the
r180
something like that yeah yeah um
because they said they didn't know how
it worked
so they literally got one out and took
it apart
and figured out how it worked just
saying how the hell do they get this
much lift from an engine this size yeah
and so that is things people we do kind
of forget things but i do think the help
of the safety aspect is a big reason why
we're not going back to the moon in any
speed but we are going back to the moon
because we want to go to mars and we
want to go to the kuiper belt and start
mining the [ __ ] out of it mine let's get
yes um so we all of a sudden i think in
the 60s it was a we must beat the
russians
yeah like what's up and then we got up
there like there's there's there's other
than scientific there's no reason to be
here and now we're like we need to go
back and it's cha-ching and amazon will
probably have the first base on moon
on the moon that's their mission that's
their mission i mean you know i know
nasa has plans through the artemis
program to build a base on the moon but
at the the rapid pace and iteration of
uh
spacex
they're they're they'll get there faster
they'll get there before nasa does
just i think it's going to because
the iss now is a blended approach you
know um they have the the falcon can
go to iss and can do missions and can do
bits and bobs and
they're already doing that they're the
the new the new the big
spacex rocket um if they slap through a
forum together can be as
good as the sls
um you know um so yeah i think there'll
be a blended approach i think elon musk
has got the idea he wants to go to mars
he'll be using nasa gateway satellite to
get there i think
um yeah and and china probably will beat
them anyway or india thinks he's got a
really good space program we send them
money for food but they've got really
good indian space for them
if you want a really good um
history of rockets especially russian
rockets i suggest a youtuber called
everyday astronaut he has several videos
on it one the difference between
um
all of these uh engines and there's a
lot of differences between all these
engines
there's another youtuber i'm trying to
find the name of he
is like how things work or something
like that
he talked with uh the
ceo of uh ula which is the ones building
the sls system and he talks about
uh
they had to buy because they you know it
was too expensive for them to go back to
the drawing board and create a new
engine they just bought them from the
russians well now buying stuff from the
russians has been problematic for some
time really problematic these days
so they turned to uh blue origin to uh
purchase of the be4 engine
for their new rocket system called the
vulcan
yeah
and then they shaped it into a spaceship
that looked like a giant willy
i don't know why they did that
but um they did
yeah i'd say i i do wonder what the the
future i think within our lifetime which
is quite exciting actually i think
within the next decade
we're going to see
um boots on the moon i think we're going
to have an orbiting space station
a blue and i think
within 10 maybe 15 years we might even
have boots on mars and actually people
living on mars permanently that's kind
of cool we're actually getting to a
point where we're almost like living the
sci-fi dream right
my
grandkids could live on mars
maybe
i mean okay so the the youtuber that had
the interview
uh of the it was a plant tour of their
rocket factory uh that is smarter every
day smarter every day here on youtube i
watched that i thought i thought it was
the astronaut i saw
i mean he does all sorts of things but
he's he's got like actually a lot of
videos
i'm thinking about
it was fascinating he was watching all
the engines being put together right
actually he actually walked him through
all the different um stages so i think
all the different um air hangers and
what they were doing and stuff it was
really fascinating yeah raptor three and
four is just gonna be insane
it's just gonna be insane
looking forward to it so i'm saying it
we're actually
we're almost getting to a point
of
what they thought the 1950s and 1960s
were going to be like yeah and you know
we're almost at that jetsons age we're
gonna get flying cars we're gonna be
living on mars
uh well
this thing i mean cell phones
i mean
yes they're ubiquitous now there
everyone's got them and
i can call and i can talk to any person
on the planet
and probably use a translator to
communicate with them
for the cost is like zero or nil more or
less you must your investments in this
thing is actually in the device not the
service
and that just blows my mind man i mean
it's literally a tricorder i can get the
weather from any point
right i can get the weather from either
laptop i don't need anything i've got
that thing i can track stars i can get
the
sorry
okay let me show you mine you know dude
it's tesla building a phone that's
amazing
ah suspicious why where for reasons we
won't go into we won't go
into it's an ugly [ __ ] ship
i'm sorry
i'm fighting words mister the end bits
look like they're gonna fall off i'm
sorry but they just are um if tesla
builds a phone i'll buy that [ __ ] yeah i
mean
i've you know i've never heard
uh actual words come out of his mouth
you know musk's mouth saying he's going
to build a phone
another starlink
uh
i uh you know here i see all these
videos right and some of the
sorry well yeah
uh it's a little operator but um
i hear there's a lot of
channels on youtube that
is it finally happened is this is the
tagline on the uh the thumbnail and like
you know um
the elon musk solves warp drives
and these guys have millions of
followers it's like how the
i mean how much [ __ ] comes out about
musks every day
you know uh like the letter you know
they came out telling musk to you know
he's an idiot
uh and then they fire the five five
people that are that were partook in
that
and some of my friends at work at spacex
said they were really
um
abused when they didn't sign it
i mean they're these the these five
people
uh were really uh aggressive and there's
a rule there's a rule in the corporate
policy and it's it's called the don't be
an [ __ ] clause yeah and that kind of
behavior is really looked at you do not
put you know you just don't do that to
other people and they were using really
um
i don't want to say stern something a
little bit stronger than stern they were
they were being an [ __ ] about it and
you and you can't be i mean you can get
fired from spacex for being a jerk to
other employees being abusive
and that's
what they got for and i've got two
witnesses that said they were approached
that way
from linkedin and said yeah they it was
um
one was threatened and it was just
you fire those [ __ ] they're because
they're yeah they had three launches
this weekend they've got three they got
several people uh in space that they got
to get back down
spacex doesn't have time for this
[ __ ] and they had to go i would have
fired them
if they weren't if they were boeing no
one would have blinked an eye
yeah
that's like i don't have any experience
of boeing i don't know what they're like
but it just it just seemed like that um
elon musk has created a company that for
one he's proud of
um but
i don't know
it's it's it's he seems to build things
the way he wants them to be rather than
the way they are sometimes
and i i can't help but
respect that you know but he does things
the way he thinks they should be rather
than the way they are sometimes
the tesla phone is supposedly going to
be out this year maybe next year maybe
five years um but i just the one bit
from the byline that gurus me a little
bit um it's uh
considering tesla's over-the-top
features and their existing products
like the cyber trucks nearly impedable
exo skill and biodefense system it is
supposedly built out of the same
material that the impenetral bioskin of
cyber truck was made out of
that's pretty much the thing that almost
went look it's unbreakable hit it with a
hammer it just shattered so uh
the steel from the cyber truck is the
same steel that's used on the uh
starship
yes apparently yeah
i mean i ca i've tweeted to uh elon musk
a couple times
can you use recycle starship to make my
cyber truck because that would you make
a spacex version it's just recycled
steel from all the
blown rockets laying around you know
south uh padre la padre island island
you know good job for me um i i want to
ask elon musk couldn't stop building a
cyber truck that looks so stupid
no one will steal it it's perfect
you just looking thing
it's not
i can't see where the function comes
from there used to be a tv show years
ago that had a car in it and the guy
there's a bitly look like tron and he
could the car used to change shapes and
things i forget what it's called but it
looked like that anyway that's what it
reminds me of those sharp edges and
things i'm just like
i'm not sure why who's going to buy that
other than stormy who will obviously
well americans they'll put f-150 on the
side of it and you'll buy it by the
you'll buy millions of the damn things
yeah i i had one f-150 i had one for
truck and
it was i know it was it was okay i drove
it for a couple hundred thousand miles
sold it
um
you know it's uh it's okay but i'm
really you know i ordered a um
i i ordered a cyber truck before the
little presentation was over on the web
i was streaming it at home oh my god as
soon as they put the the order address i
was typing in typing and typing in
you know hit print hit by
it had like gateway time out hit by hit
gateway by the
time the
the morning the sun came up the next day
i had ordered five
it's all cancelled
yeah well they don't fit on our roads
here and somebody bios has got because
he's got like um a gardening business so
he's got the f-150 raptor yeah and the
back wheels are like
three feet wide or something but he
can't get on his driveway so he has to
park it on the corner
on the path and where he the way he
lives there's this path it doesn't
really go anywhere so he just he just
fills up the entire path but every time
he drives everyone's just like jesus you
just have to get up his way
what are you doing it's just it's
enormous
yeah
you can't
um
one of the things is plant as i
understand it and this was just a brief
blurb from musk maybe three years ago he
said yeah the the cyber truck wouldn't
be available for europe but to maybe a
wolverine version that will actually fit
on your roads it has to be
it's kind of a mini truck or something
but it's still got
a slightly smaller version yeah yeah
because it's just it's ridiculously big
yeah we don't we don't need it here um
we don't we don't we just don't but
yeah hey if you like that sort of thing
that's the thing for me stuff i took i
always wanted the fall guy truck with
with the actual bird on the on the
bonnet that was i think i always wanted
one um blue
big ass chunky wheels you know the
lights on top that don't do anything
that's what i want right
and but if i win the lottery obviously
so much my three-car dream anyone ever
was always the fall guy truck
i was like so i think i've got a little
bit of american in me
we're so proud
yeah i've got i'm well we're cousins at
the end of the day
but um but not that much
my my right foot my my little toe is
american
that's where that's my little bit of
american
um but i haven't
yeah do you like i do have to admit i do
like trucks i do like
those flatbeds they make no sense here
but i do like them i just want to shout
out to ian you know i do like the
electric hummer that is it's uh you know
it's got that
can barely fit on the road kind of
profile the reason i um i'm more
enthusiastic about the cyber truck is
not necessarily the cyber truck itself
but it's the uh
the charging network here in america uh
the the tesla chargers they're faster
they're everywhere
you know in one of the uh
the
electrify america and some of the other
ones
they're the this they're just not there
i mean in terms of a product
uh i mean if you read through um
the forums for other electric like the
chevy bolt or whatever
or the uh new ford e-mustang or whatnot
everyone hates the charging and it works
and they go back to uh combustion
combustion engine or they buy a tesla
which has really solved that problem the
the the inten unless you've got the
charging infrastructure
and have access to the charging
infrastructure
um
yeah i i i think the electric car me and
my wife have both gone electric in the
last six months here in the uk and it is
a bit of a problem
and we could charge our car about 80
in 30 minutes when we can find the fast
charging points but on the motorways
most of the um charging points we in
this country we have there has to be
charging points every service station
right oh okay some of them don't have
them but it's by law for about five
years that they're supposed to but they
don't have them or they don't work
um i can't wait for tesla's charging
points to be made available to everybody
because they've got their charging
points just so much better but not
everyone here you can only use them here
if you got tesla
so which i don't have because i'm not
that real wealthy um but to be honest if
the charging points were better i
wouldn't have a problem with my electric
car at all i can drive two and a half
hours on a charge sensibly
right and then you have to stop for half
an hour i need to stop half an hour
after that anyway i need a wee
i'm old
and i need a cup of tea
um because i'm british so i'm like i'm
two hours i'm like i need a cup of tea
and a doughnut damn it
you know so so for me it doesn't bother
me i can drive about i can drive about
three hours and then i have to stop you
know
you're dead but if the charging points
were better so i could charge the car in
about half an hour i'd be happy as larry
but once or twice we've stopped and
either not been able to charge it
because the charging point has been
broken which is just maddening or it's
the slower one and it takes about an
hour and an hour to be honest it's a bit
too long you don't want to stop for an
hour
you know that's that's having having a
lovely dinner three-course meal sort of
time you're like you see great greatness
like now come on
half an hour would be fine
so walter brings up
an issue electric vehicles take ages to
charge the battery supplied by cold
burning energy plants limited places to
charge it
limited range and they bloody well blow
up
uh when they do blow up they blow up
very very well
yeah yeah so um when they do burn they
burn
when they do burn they burn um
it's very rare though there's more
combustion there's more fires in cars
from combustion engine and this is per
capita than there are electric vehicles
that's not just tesla that's all
electric vehicles
the uh the batteries are
now at least i'm not sure about chevy or
ford but at least for tesla they are
recycled
electric vehicles uh
typically take
if you're at a fast charging station
they take about a half hour less
to charge they're always located near
restaurants tesla's always had a policy
to put them into restaurants
if you look at my sci-fi channel
hotel yeah yeah a lot of the time
um
and most people that uh
coal burning energy plants there's more
we have all sorts of ways to make
electricity in america not just coal
burning i mean we could not salt we
cannot supply all the energy america
needs just from coal there's just not
enough of it
but even if you do charge your tesla
with
electricity from 100 coal
it's still cleaner
than it is
if you just use gasoline for the same
miles
yeah
yeah a big power station is generating
electricity in a central location on
large scale is more efficient and
therefore less
yeah polluting the thing i'd also argue
that the next generation batteries
are going to be even better again and
there's you know a lot of these silicon
based batteries that are coming through
can charge in five or ten minutes they
think yeah um which is just fantastic
and can charge a thousand times before
they they feel they need replacing which
again
and they reckon they get four 500 miles
out of each charge so in that case
you've got a car that the batteries can
well outlive your car
because it's for 500 000 mile range my
cars
you know most cars are dead after 200
000 miles and they say
um
the infrastructure for the charging is
the only difference but to be honest
with here um we're getting solar panels
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
charge my car during the day it'll yeah
my car just off it's completely free
here in america i think it's maybe just
california but i know there's a lot of
states like this
if you build a new house it has to have
solar panels on it period there's no you
can't get as a building permit f-150s
godsend for what i love i love my f-150
it just
pops
yeah it is yeah it's it's you know um
yeah they sell one now
now now they sell like one every like
four seconds or something to do what
they do it really is in fact uh the
f-150 the the trucks the f-150 250 f-250
that series of trucks
um
it's the most uh
popular thing ford has in fact ford
stopped making a lot of their passenger
cars and are just focusing on trucks
hydrogen cell technology is i mean it's
a viable technology the problem is you
need
let's say you have x amount of kilowatts
right
do you use those kilowatts you have
available to
how to charge a battery or to sp or do
you use that same amount of kilowatts to
split hydrogen
even though if you use ac which is much
more efficient ac power to split
hydrogen from water
if you split it then you have to turn
that into electricity so
it has hydrogen has a really good
promise for aviation
because you know the
uh you can just you still have to carry
the fuel on board in this case it'd just
be water and you could just just in time
split it and then use it in the engine
or just use liquid hydrogen you know
refuel illegal hydrogen at the airport
but from a car
you don't really care carry that care
that much about the mass on the road
because it's the road you don't have to
lift everything up into the sky so
hydra's a very good uh
uh in fact there's a lot there's many um
companies that's ones in england i think
it's a zero avia i think it is
uh that is really doing great work in
aviation and hydrogen power
um i think the um
the couple of things i say about
hydrogens is it seems to be that we're
moving towards guys
buses and things like that we already
have hydrogen bushes we haven't in my
hometown right anything big
seems to work really well of hydrogen
because there are little complications
with hydrogen very cold days are a
problem with hydrogen things like so you
have to have like heat in there
there's quite a lot so stuff that's big
the really big exciting thing for me is
like um jcb here in the uk have built an
engine that um that looks like
a normal like diesel engine but it's not
it's a hydrogen engine and they're
saying for us electric
for a jcb and big you know like um big
works trucks that electric just isn't
viable for a long time
you know it's just like um i charge my
car once a week at the moment
um because i only do about 200 miles a
week
so i understand jcbs they can't be going
around all day but so they've got this
hydrogen engine that's been funded and i
think so i think for big stuff
hydrogen's the way to go
for little stuff and for your car
batteries but it's going to be but i
think walter's got a point in that
right now it is a bit of a pain in the
ass having i have an electric car now
and i have to admit it's a bit of a pain
next gen though i thoroughly expect my
next car or probably the one after that
to have batteries that charge very very
fast last two three hundred thousand
miles
and and give me the range i need but
also that most importantly the network
to charge it will be better because it
improves every year
so yesterday i passed the gas station
that was charging seven dollars and 71
cents a gallon
with that and it the gas
i can't even fill up my gas my my toyota
anymore
because the pump comes cuts off
automatically at a hundred dollars so i
have to like begin to refi i mean it's
crazy
uh so
you know w all of these little nuances
let's call them or or or aggravations of
electric cars because it's a new system
we i mean we moved off of steam at one
point in time i would gladly put up with
you know for just
cheaper fuel i mean so
in the cyber truck it's rumored to be
about 600 plus
miles per charge
to charge it up and go that 600 miles
will cost me about 15 at current
electrical rates
i'm looking at more than 250
with the car i have now
yeah so and
in my car at this limit it's range is
about 230 miles and that's a combin
toyota fj cruiser yeah six cylinder
my current because i did the math
um my electricity has just gone up to 30
pence a kilowatt and my um
car requires 25 kilowatts
so i mean you can do the math i think it
costs me about five pounds to charge my
car and but that's actually shot up uh
electricity price in uk would have gone
up i think it sure is i'm sure it's the
same everywhere i literally supposed to
have shot up recently it was half that
so it cost me even less than that it's
five to six pounds to charge my car at
home and i do 200 miles on that so in
that case my old car used to cost me 70
pounds to fill up and it was about 300
miles right and then to do 300 miles now
cost me nine pound
so uh
kevin's got a good question uh
where does electricity come from here in
california if you look at um
[Music]
a place called tehachapi look at some of
the images around there i live nearby
most electricity comes from these huge
windmills
uh also a lot of our electricity comes
from immense solar panel arrays at least
from where i'm at most electricity comes
from renewable sources
and it was also that way when i lived in
oregon uh didn't use any real fossil
fuels everything was either
wind uh solar or hydro hydrate uh
hydroelectric
uh so uh
walter gas shortages are on purpose mr
trump don't get me started on that you
know one thing i like about electric
cars is i no longer have to give the
saudis one more dollar of mine
you know i mean there is not a big dial
in the oval office at the white house
that the president can just turn
no i think this is one of the biggest
grabs for cash ever i mean this is all
manufactured shortage there's plenty of
oil on the ground plenty of capacity
we're just not using it on purpose
but anybody can agree that oil isn't
finite
you know it isn't infinite i should say
it's finite so regardless what you
believe
unless you're a complete
idiot
you must know that electric cars are the
the way to go eventually
when you might not want to do it now you
might not like it but eventually you're
going to have to switch your electric
because
oil will run out eventually or it'll
just get actually what'll happen first
is it'll get so expensive that it's no
longer practical
unless you're got a ferrari or something
then no one cares really yeah the way to
go what i'm hoping will happen is most
people will switch to electric and then
we will be able to have a nice petrol
cars if you want to for the weekend but
at the end of the day whether you
whether you believe
in
um
global warming or anything else is
irrelevant
petrol is
finite it's going to run out eventually
and they do pollute
and unless you want
unless you are happy
that asthma rates go up 10 every smeg in
year and that they are polluting then
electric cars are the way to go they
just are
and they're really quiet so you can
sneak up behind people and they don't
hear you and then you can pick your horn
and watch them jump
it's hilarious
i do it often i keep i keep getting
um but i stopped behind people i'm
thinking why you know they're walking on
the road like why are they moving i keep
forgetting they can't hear me
it's just because my car is silent
um
oh good everyone so walter has a a a
comment about the uh
green energy in texas
uh i'm guessing walter you're referring
to the brutal cold snap was it last year
yeah um
well there's you know this kind i know
somebody way up the stream asked us not
to talk about politics but it's kind of
coming back this is another man-made
problem
um
the texas is not connected to the rest
of america in terms of electrical grid
it is totally isolated
and texas
is responsible for the grid in texas
and texas whoever is in charge has taken
great steps not to upgrade
their uh their grid
in fact during the winter months
they add on a
capacity
in terms of traditional fossil fuels
because solar is not going to be
is not going to be as much so they kind
of discount that
and even with discounting solar on the
grid during those winter months
texas's grid went down
and that was because there was coal
there but the coal was frozen and
couldn't be put into
the uh furnaces
natural gas the valves froze and that's
a i mean there was lots of problems but
it was all on the fossil fuel side
the people that had like solar panels
they were all warm and toasty there were
people that were using their tesla cars
to live in because they've got a tesla
cars has a small little heat pump
you know they had like a three days
worth of heating
so
uh yeah i mean it's um
green green energy is doable at least
it's doable for me and it's doable for
the people that had it in texas because
that's how they got through the crisis
california new construction sorry i
don't know what that means toy way to
hydrogen give it a look
uh yeah i just there's r schwarzenegger
tried to build what's called the
hydrogen highway
20
20 00 something
yeah and uh he was uh hydrogen buses in
public
and that never took off and the only uh
hydrogen station i know of is at the
mojave spaceport there's one there
and there's just none where i live near
me that i know of
and so also the
uh hydrogen powered toyotas you have to
live in los angeles to buy one they're
not available you can't just go buy one
you have to yeah you can only lease them
you can't buy them
and i've got an fj cruiser in the you
know i have a certain need for that type
of a vehicle
uh and toyota doesn't have anything that
to replace
the fj cruiser they don't even have a
gas
analogy for my fj cruiser to sell me
i think first here in the uk
we're going green solar panels are only
about 30 effective for us because um i
don't know if you know this about
britain
reigns quite a lot
um it
you might have been mentioned i might
have mentioned it on here once or twice
last year when you were going about
hours 100 degrees and i'm not going yeah
it's pissing down here
um
you know it's like it rains quite a lot
here um we've got all fresh water we're
going to tap our rivers and sell it to
you lotsu
and we're
we're the new saudi arabia but it's
going to be water
we've got wales wales is full of it
it's just like just clouds
don't pull this wealth on us
um but we're looking at tidal
because they're saying because it
doesn't matter
um
the sun can go away fair enough
the tide doesn't stop and then reckon
we've got enough fuel we could we could
charge most of europe if we could yeah
you could i
did
one percent of our tide just to tidal
energy that's capable because you can't
put it everywhere because there would be
environmental impact um but if we could
tap one percent of it we could charge
all of britain's needs
forever
and we never will get to that but
um there's another thing that um yes
shelley we came in late we came in early
cause it's father's day i should have
said sorry
um i could i gotta go do a meal a little
bit but um
solar panels for us are a good one
though because we can put solar panels
in north africa where the solar energy
is far more efficient it's close to like
80 efficient
and then just put in power cables we've
already got a couple power cables that
come through gibraltar and into spain
and then they would they join our
electrical um grid or some of them they
actually go around spain and go straight
to britain
um but europe has or is connecting its
its entire grid
so we're gonna have one big grid across
europe
um it's because it's really good because
you can shift the power can't you
because we've got three time zones
the nine o'clock rush it can shift
you can shift the need across the grid
um but the main thing is they were
talking about how well this isn't going
to work because it's going to cost 6
billion dollars or six billion pounds to
build um the power cables between um
north africa and um to join to connect
to our grid
and there was oh well that's absorbently
expensive isn't it like well no because
we're building a nuclear reactor over um
everything that's going to cost 11
billion dollars
um so
six billion was all
six bills
we have fighter planes it's a billion
each yeah exactly
free energy
basically for the rest of our lives
and you'd only need you know because
solar panels down there are so efficient
you know it's just yeah for me so
there's a there's a big
there there's a big change i don't know
if it's a change it's just improved in
efficiency that there's more that the
the the push now for solar panels is to
be more efficient in the ultraviolet
range
yeah so when it is
when it is just raining cats and dogs or
cloudy or whatever uv goes clean uv is
not blocked by clouds yeah this is one
of the ways where elon musk's is still
effective in this so they they still
work even in
the worst nightmare yeah quite like the
eevee
uv and also the next-gen solar panels
again they're lighter they're based on
provocate some some of them some
plant-based material is the is the main
thing so they're much more green and it
can go green and but it's all about
efficiency if they get more efficient
but i think we're in i know there's
still a bit of a um an argument going on
walter's still saying about yeah and
efficiently the problem is we we're on
the cusp of it
he's right
it's current solar panels they don't
last very long they can't be recycled
and they're not particularly efficient
but the next gen ones
are going to be better again the solar
panels 10 years ago were much worse
they're better today in five years
they'll be better again they're getting
cheaper all the time they cost about 10
what they did 10 years ago because
they're just cheaper you know because we
build more of them they're much cheaper
so i mean
we're on the cusp electric cars i've got
like say from a man of experience
95 of the time my electric car is
absolutely fine
i do have to really think about long
journeys in advance
but i used to do that anyway because i
have to stop every three hours to pee
anyway
so
um
but the next gen will be better again
after that they'll be better again and
that's the thing we're on the cusp of
having technology we can use
for me yeah andrew makes a good point
hydro is the way it goes as far as
renewables yeah it's
or the pacific northwest really uses a
lot of hydroelectric
uh back there's so much hydroelectric uh
they closed down i think is the boardman
coal plant and no one even no one
noticed
you know there's so much hydroelectric
and also geothermal and wind and solar
there
the the thing about renewables is there
are lots of ways to generate electricity
lots of ways
there's only one way to get fossil fuel
from a fossil
limited and it's getting in
in in
the thing about coal is i mean i grew up
in a coal mining family
you know my grandfather my
great-grandfather all months and or all
my uncles that worked in the mine they
all died of coal mining either they were
trapped in a coal mine they died of
either
some rock falling on them i remember my
uncle dewey died because it was called a
kettle bottom fell on him and crushed
him to death
and if you've never held the hand to
somebody dying of black lung
then you don't know
the other side of the equation of how
bad cole is
remember my grandfather he
minutes
hours before he died he would cough up
these big tar balls and he had to have a
suction to pull him out of his throat
uh we've got to get off a coal unless
you just want more appalachian miners to
die for no reason so you can have your
tea kettle electric tea kettle going and
you don't want to use solar power
actually heavy's got a really good point
here that actually the most efficient
way of doing things is to have a
well-run classic vehicle
that you don't recycle you know i didn't
like if you've actually got an old car
from the 70s but it's running well
keeping that running if you think about
your carbon footprint it's actually
really really green
well it's like the the green
it's like the greenest house you can buy
is the one that's already built
yeah exactly in the carbon
buildings
yeah and
you know the batteries in my green
electric car um
i've been all over the world to be made
it's not very green um but yeah so i i
think that yeah if we could all have a
1971 chevy monte carlo
then that is the most green you can be
as long as as long as it's well
maintained and looked after but the
thing is
if enough of us get off petrol cars and
we stop buying newer petrol cars we can
enjoy these classic beautiful
petrol cars more
um that were just
better
everything was better in the 70s and
then the 80s came along and ruined
everything but you know like
classic beautiful cars that we can
actually appreciate
you know is um is hopefully the future
hey uh heavy chevy uh
what is your what's the rust problem i
mean how how do you combat the rust on
your monte carlo
you're a 71 run a carlisle i'm just i'm
just because i've got a quick uh maybe
he lives in maybe lives in texas could
be well maybe so
anyway if you're having problems with
rust there's a product called corrosion
x we use it in the aircraft industry
apply it once uh once a year
and it'll really help with
with any kind of corrosion problem you
have with those old cars
okay pro tip there we go let's end this
marvelous conversation
that we didn't talk about sci-fi
at all i tried i really tried
we live in the future man we live in the
future it's hard to talk about sci-fi
these days it was the walter show today
he drove that he drove most of the
conversation and that's not a bad thing
um
get some bells on a red light they
burned oil right there
that's true well chevy heavy has seems
to be very particular about things in
his throat okay
yeah elect and this is the thing as well
as my electric car i swear to god it's
not boring it's the it's the most fun
car i've ever driven can i ask what
you're driving
well i've got a little e up
and so i've got a little car but then
the wife's got um the electric corsa fox
or courser so
running mid-sized cars
um i've got my little e up is tiny it's
something about that big uh honestly we
could fit four of them in my living room
oh walter don't complain at all
yeah oh no no no no no this this is the
whole point of today but
naught to about 50 miles an hour
um it'll put even my little e up will
it's so much fun up like naught to 40 50
mile an hour it's just lightning and you
can throw it around corners it's the
most it's it is like it is like a dodge
you have dodgems in america
you know like the little um thingy cars
at the at the fun fair
you know and you can no you don't know
what i'm talking about what else would
they call them cars or bumper cars
it's like that but my electric car is
like that all day i'm just driving a
bumper car all day it's it's it's
fantastic um i actually i really really
the power is
the talk is so um you know immediate
it's
i imagine i can't imagine what proper
big sporty electric cars feel like
because i'm honestly i can in my little
tiny little 25 kilowatt car i
can't it's loads of fun
you should try it
and yeah
don't worry about it yeah don't worry
the um
the tesla model s is so fast in the zero
to 60 that if you're at a
stoplight before you get
out of the intersection
just a typical intersection you're
already past 60 miles an hour before you
get out of the intersection
i have to be genuinely careful and
there's a traffic light by me that's
just got a speed camera on it um and
it's 30 mile an hour because you're not
allowed to only go 30 mile an hour on
the island i stop at the red light
um i
um have to be careful that i don't go
too fast when i'm getting off the line
that i because i'm still in the um speed
camera zone
and i can i can go i can be hitting 40.
i'm certain i could hit 40 but it within
20 meters
is it nice just going with that it's
probably only 10 to 15 meters and i'm
but honestly
it's great it is a golf cart but it's a
fun it's it's just it's just loads of
them yeah what's the 060 of the model s
is it 1.9
yeah like two yeah it is like two
seconds who's that there's something
60 in my wife's car is which is a voxel
corsa which is not an expensive or you
know like
it is considered to be one of the better
ones for the price range her naught to
60 is six seconds
in a family i think if she put it in
sport and puts it on thingy mine mine is
about um mine's about nine seconds but
that's more because it's not heavy
enough so the wheels spin
i can spin the front wheels in my car
which i've never noticed you know it's
like as this car got traction control um
but it's just too much talk
the talk is astonishing but yeah hers
will properly put you back in your seat
in a little family
you know
hatchback
which i just find so i i'm dying to
drive
a proper
you know expensive quality sport you
know electric car because it was just
they just must be so much fun
yeah there's a there's a guy um
i think he lives near you it's
uh jack sucks at life he's a youtuber
and he has a model three he does a lot
of videos on it he may have a whole
channel devoted to his model three he
does all sorts of crazy fun little
experiments like he uh he got his
girlfriend one of those uh traffic cone
costumes and he's trying to see if the
uh
if the autopilot recognized
that's an obstacle
uh yeah he does that kind of stuff so
it's very interesting to watch
my annoys me it drives me crazy i'll be
it keeps trying to pull the foot
steering wheel like man's they can see
the white lines and things and things oh
you want to go that way bloody don't
stop me
i'm trying to dodge the squirrel
yeah i i actually think that is a
serious point about electric cars i
think there will be more accidents
because they are really really fast off
the line that naughty 40 mile an hour
they are lightning quick
and i honestly think there could be more
accidents
they're too fast
yeah most people are not used to that
kind of uh performance and they just
well because they floor their you know
their truck or their sedan
and
[Music]
this is
at least you actually put my foot
for the floor basically in this car you
have to you have to slowly put your you
but it
you know
i think it's ford that has a setting
that um
it's somewhere in the in the in the
settings in the control panel for the
truck
uh to
even though you floor it
it won't translate that command to the
it'll quickly accelerate you but it
won't give you all the power it won't
translate all the power to the wheels
to help you not kill yourself because
these things i mean they're low center
of gravity you can corner just like like
a laser around on train
and it's just that you can get well the
car can get way ahead of you
uh because it's just so powerful and
quick
even my little one that's got like this
not got the biggest engine is you know
it's got it it's quick i worry about
mine um if it's wet going on corners but
the right mind is because it's not a
heavy car it's a very light vehicle so i
i've actually felt like me [ __ ] the leg
one stroke the back wheel there's lots
that has left the ground because i've
gone around the corners too quick but
it's just so much fun to drive
um well walter i mean what about all the
other statements that uh uh
that he said that he did get what about
you know when we take a telescope
pointed at the apollo landing sites that
we see all the stuff that they took
there and left there i mean you just you
if you want to come up with a theory
that's fine but you also have to accept
the um the evidence that goes against
your uh premise
yeah i mean you just can't take one side
of the story you know so yeah he he i
don't and i don't think he exactly said
what you whoever the youtuber was he's
saying you know because i remember with
buzz aldrin somebody said he never went
to the moon he [ __ ] punched the guy
and that was awesome
and even the judge said dude
pay him twice
right guys we are we are going to have
to make call it an evening because i
need to go see my dad on father's day
i'll go that's why we we did this early
one and then we've ran over by half an
hour anyway
so um but that's mostly thank you to
walter so again don't apologize sir
um what's this the truth is there if you
want to know it is that's our point
that is 100 our point
it is there
um thank you so much for everybody thank
you for everybody's got involved today
it's been it's been a good lap against
guys everybody in the comments
you make us laugh and um i can't wait
for hyperloop oh i want hyperloop too
magnetic trains and stuff i love it
um
yes we're punching the videos part of
astronauts gone wild yeah okay father's
day in september here uh yeah you know
it's today here we we just we just
completely translate mother's day is
completely different for you guys as
well isn't it
um but thank you so much
mother's day is in april for us so march
first well i'm pretty sure today's
father's day
here in america i think
here's in uk too oh actually i'm not
sure
i'm trying to remember i told you that
this
i'm saying this on and when i do my live
show the other day
the amazing things i talk to people from
all over the world now having this this
this show and i forget where everyone
comes from
um but it's um it's absolutely
andrew might be australian
um
but you'll have to tell me if you'll
tell me in a minute but um andrew is
actually one of my favorite people on
youtube because he's actually been a
member of the channel pretty much from
the start
i think he's pushing like six months or
something
um which is just phenomenal and thank
you so much and he kept bugging me can i
give you money so you can buy a better
speaker
i've now got a better microphone so um
so that's partly because of andrew so
thank you very much so
before we go should i do another uh
science ama this saturday uh after this
show on my channel
if you'd like i think i mean would you
think
i'm gonna fail yes i give you permission
okay well thank you very much and i just
got to figure out you know what i want
to talk about i'm on the mainland
i'm triggered
[Laughter]
calm down american
yeah
this is how the iraq war started
americans get triggered
the first one not the second one that's
completely different
i've lost track
which one
stormy norm in that one right guys
i'm out of here
go over apparently stormy you're going
to be on your channel you're going to
yeah probably give me a few minutes to
get it all set up and think of something
starkey to title it yeah
go over onto skyworks and watch that um
i will i might jump in the comments
gosh
i'm just going to shout ally minnie
mikey a lot in the comments and then and
completely spam you
oh my god the solar roads oh jesus
we're moving on
good night guys have a lovely
see you soon and uh i gotta find the
outro found it
[Music]
you